hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from everything
masters the second stage of the
champions chess tour and again it's a 12
player event with some of the players
from the first event some of them are
new uh we're gonna discuss that a bit
later on and uh
well uh it's everything as usual they
are fighting for a lot of money sixty
thousand dollars is the first place
and again it's a rapid tournament so 15
minutes per player and you get some
increment
i i think it's 10 seconds increment from
starting from one
and of course no draw offers allowed
before move 40.
uh so first three days will be the
preliminaries and then we go into the
knockout phase of the tournament uh so
without further ado let's check it out
it's a nice game from round one magnus
carlsen versus eleven arnon
so let's see what happens uh magnus uh
with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by
11
c4 we have e6 knight to f3 and d5 the
queen's gambit declined is on the board
uh knight to c3 and bishop to b4 the 11
goes for the aragosan defense and now
a nice captures captures and bishop to
f4 magnus plays this very often
c6 and now e3 so both players just uh
defending their central pawns with
bishop to f5
and now queen to b3 uh the eleven
already had this position uh against uh
laquan liam
last year in the super bad blitz uh
where bishop to e2 was played and that
game ended in a draw here magnus tries
queen to b3
goes after the bishop also tries to get
11 to take uh
take the the the knight here on c3 but
11 just goes queen to b6
which means he most likely is interested
in a queen trade
so knight the h for by magnus going
after the bishop and here eleven uh
retreats with bishop to e6 there is one
game in the database haruka duronavalli
played it against
barry neal in 2015 poker stars isle of
man stars champion
uh ship where bishop to g6 was played
but here bishop to e6 is a new move
uh sorry bishop to g6 is a new move so
already as of move nine we have a
completely new game and this is
basically where our game starts
uh so magnus eliminates the bishop uh
captures captures and now just goes h3
as the h file opened up now for eleven's
rook
so makes sense the uh to play h3 also
take away the g4 square from levin's
knight
knight b to d7 uh continuing development
preparing the castle queen side and
bishop to d3 now magnus also continues
developing pieces
and c5 level now strikes in the center
and says
that he is now ready to go queenless
so a3 attacking the bishop and now
bishop to a5 you could also capture on
c3 if you're not
interested in a queen trade then maybe
the queen would capture
but here we have queen back to a5 and
now uh the queen trade is offered so
magnus of course trades
queen captures with bishop captures and
d captures on c5
we have knight captures on c5 attacking
the bishop and here
magnus just castles you'd think maybe
bishop to c2 is
is a good move because it also covers
the
b3 square but it's not a problem because
after castles
for example knight to b3 checking c2 the
knight has to go back so there's no need
to actually
prevent the knight from coming to c2
which is sometimes useful sometimes you
think
uh oh no i i really don't want my
opponent's piece to get
to that square but then if you look into
it then you realize it's perfectly fine
so maybe you just allow it and he plays
a bad move
so here are 11 castles also and
now comes king to b1 a nice prophylactic
move by magnus and 11
uh cannot do such a thing because the
bishop covers the square so
carlson's king is a bit safer there so
knight to e6 of course levin wants to
deal with this
bishop threat and bishop to e5 of course
magnus not interested in trading it's a
wonderful bishop
so bishop to c7 11 now forces the trade
so bishop captures we have king captures
and bishop back to c2
now magnus wants to organize an attack
against the d5 pawn he wants to play
bishop to b3 add another attacker here
and just g5 when you have a doubled pawn
such as these uh you
you you want to advance your double pawn
because then if
magnus pushes anything forward you can
just trade it you get rid of your pa
a double pawn and then your position is
fine again so
bishop to b3 most of the times
and now as the pawn is attacked three
times just king c6 11 defends it
we rook to c1 now threatening some nasty
discoveries and of course 11 brings the
king to the center king to d6
and although it looks scary for example
rook hd 1 looks scary but
the pawn is sufficiently defended is
defended three times and attacked three
times
not much for you to look forward to e4
kind of is the threat but king e5 and
11 11 will survive this so magnus goes
for a different line he says
all right i can't do anything about the
d5 pawn for the moment i'm going to go
grab a pawn on a7 and
11 doesn't seem to be bothered by losing
this pawn
so knight b5 check we have kinked e5 and
now
knight captures on a7 so magnus grabs a
pawn
11 has a very active king so let's see
what happens knight to e4
eleven goes after the f2 pawn and knight
back to b5
uh grabbing the f2 pawn now is possible
but then you kind of have to deal with
rook to
f1 and it's hard uh hard to see or
where this is going so first we have g4
uh trying to get the h file to open up
uh and now
rook to c2 here magnus defends the f2
pawn as
lemon uh missed his chance to grab it
and now comes rook to h5
uh sorry not h4 rook to h5
11 now is preparing to double up on the
h file
so uh f3 uh kicking the knight away from
such an active square
g capture spawn captures and knight to
g3 now
and now you have to give up control of
the h3 pawn because
there's no way to keep it if rook h2h2
just knight f1
attacks the rook and the e3 pawn so not
not a lot of fun
so rook the d1 instead by magnus and now
knight to f5 going after the e3 pawn
first there's always time to capture on
h3
so look the c3 defending and now 11
still doesn't go after the pawn first
knight to e7 uh now he can advance
these pawns the knight uh knights nicely
control all of these squares
so he's very safe even with his king all
the way on e5 so here
knight to c7 uh of course magnus wants
to infiltrate the seventh rank with the
rook so he wants to trade knights
and g5 so here we have knight captures
on e6
and 11 says okay thank you f captures on
e6 he strengthens his
center the d5 pawn is nicely protected
now and he will now
deal with with the h3 pawn and here
magnus goes for the active
rook the c7 e4 was also a possibility
uh because you cannot capture the rook
would hang but then you also have to
take this into consideration but then
the e6 pawn is weak
so it's a bit of a trade-off so here
rook the c7 by magnus
and now knight to f5 again going after
this e3 pawn and only now e4 by magnus
so uh of course you still cannot capture
the rook would hang so knight
to d4 now attacking the bishop on b3
and here just rook captures on b7 uh
rook the c3
is kind of the the engine's
recommendation as it's
the safest move but magnus goes for the
tricky rook captures on b7
and here he allows 11 to
take the upper hand but 11 goes for rook
captures on h3 which is the correct move
but not
the correct move in the correct move
order rook captures an h3 is fine but it
doesn't come with a threat if you first
play d
captures an e4 magnus recaptures and
then you play real captures on h3 then
rook captures on h3 comes with a threat
as
the bishop and b3 would now be attacked
twice magnus would have to deal with it
and then you can either pick up the pawn
start pushing your pass pawn
and so on so oh it's a very very simple
idea but uh you know makes makes all the
difference in the world
but like i said they're playing a 15
minutes uh per player so of course so
you cannot
spend all the time on your moves so 11
captures on h3
and now magnus of course trades on d5
captures we have captures and
rook the e7 check now getting the king
away from the knight
uh but king the d6 also comes with an
attack on the rook so of course you have
to move the rook
rook e3 and now knight captures on b3
capturing the pawn here doesn't make all
that much sense because you
lose the d5 pawn so instead knight
captures on b3
we have rook captures on b3 and now rook
to f8
a double attack on the f3 pawn 11 trying
to win his pawn back
and rook d to d3 the pawns the pawn is
now nicely defended and
magnus is up a pawn in a double rook end
game maybe he can start pushing those
two connected pawns
so uh rook to f4 and now
of course preventing this a4 idea so
king c2 magnus starts improving the
position of his king
king to e5 level does the same and now
rook to b5 putting pressure on the pawn
here
and now 11 needs to decide what to do
here whether to capture
or to defend 11 defense with rook to d4
but uh unfortunately for for lemon this
rook to d4 idea loses the game so feel
free to pause the video here
and beat 11 while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh also my dad got me this cool uh king
usb stick for christmas so you can check
that out while you're thinking
uh let me just put that back in see it's
a very nice
usb stick uh king thingy
or 32 gigabytes no less uh but yeah
uh for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on beating 11 aaron
in this position and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's f4 uh with check and now uh the
problem is
the rook on h3 hangs g captures on h4
and rook captures on h3
amazingly magnus did not play this like
i said it's a 15 minute
uh rapid game and
they were both very low on the clock so
instead after this
rook to d4 move uh sorry after rook to
d4
magnus just captured the rook and this
is uh
unfortunately as you'll see not enough
so king captures on the e4 and rook to
b3 now defending
the pawn but it's not a problem rook h2
check king to b1
and now rook back to h3 defending the
pawn with
king to a2 and now comes king
king to c4 again putting pressure on the
rook rook the c3 check
king to b5 and now king to b3 preparing
to push the pawn
so d4 11 attacks the rook rook to d3 and
now king c5 really making it hard for
magnus to push those past pawns
came to c2 now maybe magnus can start
pushing
rook to g3 we have a for by magnus and
now
rook to g2 with check rook to d2
defending and again
rook to g3 11 threatening to pick up the
f3 pawn
uh rook back back to f2 now defending
the pawn from behind and now
king to b4 attacking the a4 pawn and
even though magnus is up upon levin's
king is much more active
and magnus is uh not able to
to further advance those pawns so here
11 finds a very sneaky idea
g4 now you have to capture or
maybe you don't maybe you can push f4
it's very interesting because it comes
with a pawn sacrifice and and then you
continue pushing your pawn
but it's not enough d3 check came to c1
and now king c3 is super dangerous
f6 rook a3 threatening checkmate so you
have to prevent that
king b2 king b1 and now d1 d2 is just a
game over
you'd have to defend with rook f1 rook
characters on a4
and then we can even play the south f7
and the fancy
rook the f4 wins the game for black
because either get rid of the spawn
or rook captures and it's a nice
checkmate queen check you go here queen
check you go here queen to b2 is
checkmate
so very interesting but f4 does not work
for for magnus so magnus goes fcat
person g4
d3 a nice tuition 2 before recapturing
king to d2 and now
rook captures on g4 and now the other
point will fall as well
king captures on d3 rook to g3 check
first
king to c2 and now rook to c3 with
check 11 even wants to pick up the b3
pawn with check if king b2 is played
so king b1 uh rook captures on b3 with
check
rook to b2 and here we have a nice clean
board
rook captures king captures and the king
captures on a4
so yeah uh really really wild game uh
but that's
what happens in pretty much every round
since uh you know it's not classical
chess it's rapid chess
uh and i know you guys i enjoy lower
time controls much more than you do
classical chess because that's like
i don't i don't know if we could go back
to all all that many classical
tournaments now because
uh well it's like three rounds with all
the games drawn i don't know it'd be
it's of course a much more precise chess
but it's not not as
exciting so yeah 11 did give him a
chance here after this rook to d4 move
but
that's just it you do not expect 11 to
make a mistake like this so of course
you do not realize
f4 and you pick up the rook so always
always
expect the unexpected uh but yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it we're going to check out a
few more games and then we're going to
discuss the standings
if you have your favorite use hashtag
suggestion and i will check it out
i would like to thank maurice kochlin uh
render hoykers uh
tinley ryan goggins and john nielsen for
john nelson for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and uh i will see you soon continuing
the coverage of the
air things masters checking up any
wonderful suggestions and whatever
happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day